[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
wie ihr eine leckere torte im embryo
ganz einfach selber machen könnt an
zutaten brauchen wir 600 gramm kalte
schlagsahne 400 gramm tiefkühl hin
werden oder frische man kann auch
blaubeeren eben für einen blauen
farbverlauf 220 gramm oreo kekse 60
gramm geschmolzene butter 130 gramm
zucker 12 blatt gelatine ist es egal ob
die rinder oder schweine gelatine
benutzt und 500 gramm joghurt ich hab
ihr zehnprozentigen es geht aber auch 35
prozentiger als erstes lasse ich die
gelatine fünf bis zehn minuten lang in
kaltem wasser einweichen
in der zwischenzeit berate ich schon mal
meinen boden vor
dafür gebe ich die oreo kekse in mein
mixa unser kleiner sie
[Musik]
er kommt noch die geschmolzene butter
hinein und wird noch unter gemengt und
dann ist der boden auch schon fertig die
masse kommt jetzt in meinen
vorbereiteten wakhrah den habe ich auf
19 cm eingestellt das muss jetzt einmal
gut an gedrückt werden auf den boden und
kommt es zur weiterverarbeitung in den
kühlschrank jetzt nämlich die gelatine
aus dem wasser und drückt die einmal
ganz leicht aus so dass nur noch ein
bisschen flüssigkeit da ist den topf
gebe ich jetzt auf mein herz und der
wärme die gelatine auf niedriger stufe
bis sie flüssig ist
dann nehme ich mir löffelweise von dem
joghurt und geben mit gelatine
[Musik]
wenn ich alles mit in die gelatine
gerührt habe gebe ich noch den zucker
dazu und dann gebe ich das ganze in den
kühlschrank damit dass etwas studiert
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit kümmere ich mich
schon mal um die hin werden die kuriere
ich einmal fein und danach gebe ich sie
noch mal durch ein sieb weil ich die
stücke nicht so gerne haben das könnt
ihr aber nach belieben entscheiden
und wenn auch das erledigt ist dann
schlage ich nur noch meine sahne auf
jetzt haben wir so weit alles
vorbereitet ich nehme mir nur noch ein
paar esslöffel von der himbeer soße weg
für die deko und anschließend können wir
die schichten vorbereiten
[Musik]
meine unterste schicht sein schönes
sattes pink ergeben deswegen die mich
hier die hälfte von meinem joghurt und
zirka vier bis fünf esslöffel hindert
[Musik]
für die mittlere schicht nehme ich mir
jetzt noch mal die hälfte der übrig
gebliebenen joghurt masse und gebe der
circa ein drittel der sahne dazu
anschließend ferro ich das ganze mit ein
bis zwei esslöffeln hinweg für ihre
damit ich ein schönes feines rosa
bekomme
[Musik]
ihr könnt selbstverständlich auch vier
oder fünf farben machen damit ihren
schöneren um brave verlauf habt aber mir
haben drei farben gereicht für die
dritte schicht nämlich einfach die übrig
gebliebene sahne mit dem joghurt damit
die schönweiß ist jetzt gebe ich auf den
boden die unterste schicht und zwar die
pinkel und das ganze kommt dann für 30
minuten ins gefrierfach
[Musik]
nach der schulzeit ist die erste schicht
schon ein bisschen fester geworden und
dann gebe ich dir o seine schicht drauf
und gebe das ganze wieder für 30 minuten
ins gefrierfach
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die letzte schicht darauf
die sahne joghurt schicht und dann kommt
das ganze jetzt in meinem fall über
nacht in den kühlschrank wenn ihr sie am
gleichen tag noch anschneiden wollt dann
könnt ihr sie auch für 30 bis 45 minuten
ins gefrierfach touren und anschließend
zehn minuten bei zimmertemperatur stehen
lassen und könnte anschließend
anschneiden
[Musik]
nach der kompletten kühl zeit könnt ihr
den tortenring entfernen und an den
seiten noch einmal schön glatt streichen
die deko benötigt ihr jetzt noch 200
milliliter auf geschlagene sahne ein
paar urios und den zur seite gelegten
hinweg
[Musik]
ich zeige euch noch den anschnitt der
torte und falls euch das video gefallen
hat dann würde ich mich über ein abo und
einen daumen hoch freuen
bis zum nächsten mal auf den keks
kitchen
[Musik]